rumors are now fun the brand-new NBA
champion Golden State Warriors will
unanimously refused to go to the White
House to celebrate their title several
major sites have reported such rumors
many members of the Warriors have
criticized from personally before
athletes had skipped White House
celebrations before to earlier this year
many members of the New England Patriots
decided to forego the trip to the White
House to protest from in 2011 Boston
Bruins goalie Tim Thomas refused to
visit the White House to mate with
President Obama but Thomas explaining
quote I believe the federal government
has grown out-of-control threatening the
rights liberties and properties of the
people back in 2011 important leftist
media was one ripping in an athlete
getting involved in politics as Heath
Street reported Joe McDonald with ESPN
wrote that Tim Thomas put himself above
the team James Hardy from bleacher
report said it Thomas was a real man who
would have gone to the Boston Bruins
management and ownership returned the
money from his contract and quit the
balance of it by retiring so he could
exercise his rights to free citizen and
its boards Illustrated's Duhamel wrote
quote Tim Thomas decided to exploit a
non political event to expose his
personal political views the temptation
on the right to condemn the Patriots for
standing against Trump was strong as
well here is the truth though all of
these people have the absolute right not
to stand next to a president they don't
like and naturally I think we should
kill the tradition of winning teams
visiting the White House altogether the
presidency is not a ceremonial position
it is an executive one you wouldn't
expect the local high school regional
champs to visit the head of the local
water board for a photo-op
why should politicians treat athletes
like subjects who must visit the White
House at the whim of mana none of this
actually needs to be a big deal
according to ESPN the first board seemed
to visit the White House or the Brooklyn
Ethel antics and the Washington
Nationals back in 1865 the first World
Series team champions to visit the White
House with the Washington Senators in
1924 but both of those visits were by
local teams the first NBA champions to
visit the White House for the Boston
Celtics in 63 with JFK first
n-c-double-a champions to show up came
in 1976 but ESPN reports quote it was
Ronald Reagan who made the practice of
honor and championship came to the White
House a regular occurrence whoever
invented the practice it should die a
quick and painless death there is
nothing dumber than athletes coming to
pay homage to a president who doesn't
even watch their sports see for example
the WNBA champions who show up every
year to me
some dude who's never seen a WNBA game
and there's something odarka about the
national expectation that sports
champions must receive the blessing of
the President of the United States
separating the president from the
sporting team would also prevent the
infusion of politics into sport if we
don't want athletes getting political
there's one easy way to avoid that
eventualities prevent politicians from
trying to co-opt athletic popularity in
the first place i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench hero show okay we're going to
get you everything sessions related
we're going to get to everything Bob
Mueller related we're going to get to a
bizarre press conference yesterday at
the White House with Trump's cabinet and
we're also going to get to this big
hubbub over Alex Jones and megyn kelly
but before we get to any of that I want
to say thank you so our friends over at
Birch gold so right now it is worth
noting that gold has been up the last
five months in a row there are some
doubts about the stock market about
whether word is a stock market bubble a
real estate bubble
whatever you think there's no doubt that
you have some of your assets in gold in
precious metals and that's why I work
with my friends over at Birch gold group
they have a long-standing track record
of continued success with thousands of
satisfied clients countless 5-star
reviews an A+ rating from the Better
Business Bureau right now when you call
them you can get a comprehensive 16 page
kit which shows how gold and silver can
protect your savings and how you can
move your IRA or 401k out of stocks and
into a precious metals IRA if that's
something that you want to do to get
that no-cost no-obligation cake go to
birchgold.com slash then that is
birchgold.com slash fun make sure you
ask all your questions and then when you
decide how much you want to invest in
precious metals and as I say I have some
money in precious metals then you call
my friends over Birch gold group
birchgold.com slash then use the slash
Bend so they know that we sent you again
it's just the safe financial play okay
so what's going on in the news as always
we begin today with the attempt by the
left to get Donald Trump and then this
has now become over the top it's been
over the top for months obviously the
whole Trump Russia collusion scandal was
a was an attempt by Democrats to shift
blame from Hillary Clinton to Donald
Trump and Russia for her loss now they
are searching for an alternative
strategy well that means that today in
just a couple of hours here Attorney
General
is supposed to testify on the hill
before the Senate Intelligence Committee
now why you specifying is sort of beyond
me I'm not sure why exactly sessions is
expected to testify what he's supposed
to reveal anybody who thinks I mean I've
met senator sessions several times I've
spoken with him at length anybody who
thinks because the Jeff Sessions the
senator from Alabama is in cahoots with
the Russians to somehow affect the
election cycle or is attempting to cover
up such collusion again I don't think
they've ever met recession seeing Jeff
Sessions heard Jeff Sessions doesn't
make any sense at all
but here are some of the questions that
they're going to be asking senator
session he did something former senator
session he did something smart yesterday
he said that he wanted to have the
hearing out in the open he didn't want
to do it behind closed doors I said
yesterday I think that's smart the
reason I think that smart is because it
means that we get a first-hand look at
what he's saying we don't have to hear
the weekd information from behind closed
doors from Democrats who's been that
information in the worst possible way
here are the four questions the
Democrats will certainly ask attorney
general sessions today first they're
going to ask him if he lied about
meeting with the Russians so if you
recall one of the reasons that sessions
recused himself in the first place from
the Trump Russia investigation were
there was an accusation that he
testified in front of Congress that he
never met with the Russian government
officials that he was not involved in
any sort of collusion and then it came
out that he had had a couple of meetings
with Russian ambassador Sergei his lyac
who's widely seen as a FSB which is the
KGB an FSB operative in any case that
was overblown in the first place the
first meeting that session supposedly
had with his lai act was at a Heritage
Foundation event where there was
something like 50 other ambassador's
present that's according to the
Washington Post the second meeting that
sessions had with Kelly Act was at the
Senate offices and his lahic meet
routinely with members of the Senate
like all the time so you know sessions
has a pretty easy rebuttal their second
question that sessions will be asked
today is why FBI director former FBI
director James Comey would suggest that
there were reasons for sessions to
recuse himself beyond the meetings with
kids Liat so if you recall all the way
back to last week I know time has slowed
there's so much news last week former
FBI director testified in front of
Congress he said quote our judgment as I
recall
all the sessions was very close to and
inevitably going to recuse himself a
variety of reasons we were also aware of
facts that I can't discuss in an open
setting that would make his continued
engagement in a Russia related
investigation problematic now pretty
vague right that's pretty snaky of
combing to drop that in there and then
hide the ball behind the classified
information well what are the reasons
sessions will be asked in sessions
hasn't need the answer here do we can
say I have no idea what company was
talking about like I don't know Comey
was talking about - you know what coming
was talking about nobody knows what
Comey was talking about he's just saying
stuff okay third question the sessions
will be asked is will you stand up to
Trump so as we're going to talk about in
a few minutes here there's a rumor
flying around Capitol Hill put out there
by news next CEO Chris ruddy who's
friends with from very close friends of
Trump actually ruddy said that Trump was
thinking about firing the special
counsel Robert Mueller so this has
created all sorts of chaos inside the
Trump administration an attorney Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein had to
come out earlier this morning and say
that there was no intent to fire Bob
Mueller and that he would not
participate in the firing of Bob Mueller
sessions will be asked the same question
again I think it is worthwhile here to
note that sessions is basically being
asked what level of Independence he has
from from Barack Obama's Attorney
General Eric Holder called himself
Barack Obama's wingman and no one cared
no one cared there was always just an
assumption that the Attorney General
under Barack Obama was dirty Obama used
executive privilege in order to protect
Eric Holder and in the Fast and Furious
investigation Eric Holder used his
methodologies to try and protect Barack
Obama on multiple times so again I think
that sessions is being held to a
standard that Democrats certainly are
not being held to should sessions have
some semblance of independence
absolutely but again I think they're
asking something of sessions that is a
little bit over the top and finally they
are going to ask sessions if why he
recommended that Comey be fired after he
recused himself from front brush-up the
implication of course being mint
sessions was involved in something to
carry us then he refused himself and
then Comey was getting too close so
sessions recommended that Trump fire him
there is an alternative explanation that
makes a lot more sense here that is
there was no Trump Russia of collusion
sessions
recuse himself because he didn't want to
be the center of the Trump Russia stuff
and he thought that it would muddy the
waters and then finally Trump went to
him and said hey
do you think that we should fire this
coma guy and session said yeah I think
he's incompetent that would be the most
obvious answer but watch the media will
make hay out of the out of the hearings
today we'll make a very big deal out of
the hearings today no matter how dumb
that is and you can see how over the top
that the left is in their attempts to
get from Elizabeth Warren who was fresh
from some sort of rain dance actually
she came in out of the out of the cold
way she exited her wigwam and the
senator from Native American land eeeh
she came out and she said that session
should just be fired you should outright
be fired for what she couldn't really
explain but firing sessions look I post
sessions for being Attorney General of
the United States and you may remember
shut down further I got I got I got sent
away from the Senate for that and got
shut down and not allowed to speak again
until after the vote that was the rule I
could not speak again until the Senate
had had a chance to vote on Jeff
Sessions and then when it came out that
Jeff Sessions had lied to Congress had
lied to the Senate during his
confirmation hearing I called again for
he needs to be fired he needs to be
taken out of that job if you're not
going to be honest during your
confirmation hearing then you ought to
be gone okay again this is just
ridiculous the quote/unquote lie is that
sessions didn't remember that he'd once
shook the hand of Russian ambassador
typically a can they have one meeting
with him one time and again there are
pictures all over the Internet of
various Democratic senators meeting with
sessions but you can see that Democrats
are running in 2018 on how much they
hate Trump I keep saying this
Republicans need to get with the program
it's not enough for us you just say that
that's what's happening here because
clearly that's what's happening here
Trump has to do a good job now Trump has
to not make mistakes in a little while
I'm gonna get to Trump's response to all
of this but I just want to show you the
extent to which Democrats have lost
their mind on the impeach Trump stuff
Maxine Waters legitimately one of the
dirtiest figures in Congress during the
financial meltdown choose attempting to
get bailouts for her husband's Bank
allegedly Maxine Waters congresswoman
from from my neck of the woods actor in
California who called the LA riots and
la uprising and stood in Satan and said
it was not that violence was called for
the same person is out there shouting
impeach Trump don't know what to make of
it man Washington DC who calls himself
he's not your president
my cheeks in the boys he respects us all
okay back sector have a fact-checker
from him and I love having left his term
her aunty Maxine
she's only her aunt's in the sense that
there's this crazy old loon aunt who
shows up at your barbecues and you don't
really know who she is because she's not
related to anybody but she just seems
hungry see a theater
aunty Maxine you know yes it turns out
that trump is your president he's
everybody's president because he was
duly elected in an election in the
United States that's how things work out
here Bernie Sanders is out there doing
this routine to here is the the senator
from Boone land out there talking about
how Trump is the most dangerous
president we have ever seen he is the
most dangerous he is so dangerous I am
very much afraid he will take my pudding
cup and then I will not know what to eat
and I will be forced to bring cans of
ensure which are just not as tasty as my
pudding Bernie Sanders goal today today
in the White House we have perhaps the
worst and most dangerous president in
the history of our country
and we also have not to be forgotten
extreme right-wing leadership in the US
House and the US Senate I love how the
Democrats can't decide whether Trump was
incompetent or super dangerous oedipal
areas to watch them bounce around
between the two finally the DC and
Maryland Attorneys General how the press
conference yesterday which they
announced they were filing a loss
against President Trump they're trying
to suggest that he has violated the
emoluments Clause of the United States
Constitution the emoluments Clause of
the US Constitution bans public figures
in the United States and Western
officials from taking bribes basically
from foreign governments and they're
trying to suggest that that is what
Trump is doing with the Trump Hotel that
there's a bunch of foreigners who are
renting rooms in an attempt to get in
good with Trump here are these attorneys
general wasting the time of their
citizens and money of their citizens
earlier this morning the state of
Maryland and the District of Columbia
filed a lawsuit in federal court against
the President of the United States
the suit alleges that President Trump is
flagrantly violating the Constitution
which explicitly bars presidents from
receiving gifts or inducements from
foreign or domestic government entities
never in the history of this country
have we had a president with these kinds
of extensive business entanglements okay
look I am NOT a fan of how President
Trump has handled his business I don't
think that I think he should have
divested himself I always thought that
his his ethics rules were not stringent
enough but the idea that they're going
to be able to sue number one they don't
have standing we have something called
legal standing they can't show they were
damaged but they're trying to say that
you're damaged because one of the Trump
hotels in Washington DC or some such
nonsense
no second of all the emoluments clause
does not really talk about what happens
if the president has an ongoing business
and then ongoing business does business
with somebody else when the president
isn't running it right now Trump is
actually running his business his kids
are running the business and it's not
clear what constitutes a gift again
there were services rendered by the
Trump Hotel and people from abroad are
allowed to pay for those services not
there this amounts to a gift
the amount of squaws has always been
pretty vaguely defined particularly
since president end up receiving all
sorts of present and presents from
foreign governments remember when the
Clintons left the White House they took
a crap load of presents from foreign
governments in order to in order to
enrich themselves and that was not
considered a violation of the emoluments
clause this just goes to show you the
Democrats are just searching out there
this is not really get rid of Trump this
is all about driving out the base and
increasing the perception that Trump is
corrupt so we're going to talk about
Trump has been responding to that in
just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our friends over at my
Patriot supplies so right now North
Korea is as militant as it's ever been
there's a new study showing that the
Russians are attempting to they tend to
Dec voting machine we know that natural
disasters around the way we're hitting
hurricane season whatever you are
concerned about then one of the things
you should be concerned about is the
possibility of some sort of disaster
that renders the government unable to
give you aid for a certain period of
time you need to go and get an emergency
food supply over at my patriot supply
all you have to do is go to prepare with
been calm that is prepared with been
calm eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen you know for weak
emergency food supply for just $99 takes
care of you and your family for four
weeks emergency food supply ninety nine
bucks order now it's something out here
in California the government actually
recommends that you have emergency food
on hand nobody does it but you can be
the person who's prepared with my
Patriot supply prepare with been calm
all of this food last for years and
years and years and apparently according
to folks in the office of taste like
home cooking so only 99 bucks plus free
shipping stuff in the closet you don't
have to worry about it until disaster
cuts and then you're the person who
protected their family 888 803 1413 888
803 1413 or prepare with fend calm
prepare with been calm okay so all of
this said if it's obvious that the
agenda of the Democrats take down Trump
it would be who President Trump to
behave in the most morally rectitude in
his session he can possibly find right
that he should behave and he should be
as clean as the driven snow you should
say come in check me out everything's
great
you know welcome to Health Inspectors
everything is fine and he certainly
should not continue to boost this this
kind of widespread notion that he sees
himself as a potentate which is why it
was not great yesterday when he had a
meeting with his cat
and bunch of cameras showed up and his
cabinet members know unfortunately that
president Trump's personality foibles
mean that the best way to get through to
President Trump the best way to scan his
good side his flattery and so this just
kind of humiliating exchange happened
Reince Priebus his chief of staff says
this at the meeting in front of all the
cameras there your staff we're out here
mr. president we thank you for the
opportunity and the blessing that you've
given us to serve your agenda and the
American people and we'll keep
continuing to work very hard every day
to accomplish those goals the
opportunity and the blessing and the
Lord responded with favor two rhymes
been Richard I mean really come on come
on why you work for him like we all get
that but the entire table goes around
and thanks Trump for the opportunity to
serve you and serve the agenda Wilbur
Ross had said something similar again
this sort of stuff just does not look
good on a president I don't care who the
president is if it were a Democrat can
you imagine them operate from the right
Barack Obama had forced all of the
members of his cabinet to go around and
praise him personally for appointing
them can you imagine how that the
mockery would never end and rightly so I
mean it's sad when Chuck Schumer
successfully trolls the President of the
United States injuction was just awful
but here's the Senate Minority Leader
successfully trolling Trump yesterday I
want to thank everybody for coming I
just thought we go around the room Lucy
how do we do on the sunday show
yesterday your tone was perfect you were
right on message Michelle have my hair
look coming out of the gym this morning
you have great hair nobody has better
hair we going further I just want to say
thank you for the opportunity and
blessing to serve your agenda okay I
have to admit I laugh because the whole
thing is kind of ridiculous now is it
damning of Trump at the end of the world
no and we're not have proportion but I
just want to point out that that when it
comes to Trump most of the problems he's
had our problems of his own making and
they spring from his personality which
is volatile and egocentric and that is
not a good combo when you're presidents
of the United States he's going to need
to to get himself under control though
but we're going to talk about that in
just a second plus I want to talk about
what's happened with megyn kelly and
Alex Jones I want to talk about all of
the all of the hubbub surrounding Katy
Perry
we're going to deconstruct the culture a
little bit today because - Tuesday -
lots more coming up you're going to have
to go over to daily wire calm right now
and subscribe for that eight dollars a
month gets you a subscription to daily
wire.com plus it gets be part of the
mailbag as I say if you're wondering
part of mailbag this week I think my dad
is going to come in studio and we're
going to talk about our brand-new book
on the leg talk so if you have any
questions for my father you know
questions that you wouldn't want me to
answer about my dad but my dad can
answer about me then go over to daily
wire comm right now and subscribe $8 a
month gets you a subscription plus if
you're an annual subscribe you actually
get a copy of that very book and get a
copy of this very book right here say
itself it's about me and my dad and my
grandpa pop up all white sox fans and in
the 2005 White Sox championship season
great fathers they get to get a free
signed copy right now when you point an
annual subscriber over at daily wire
calm so go on over and check it out or
if you just want to listen later at
iTunes or SoundCloud gone over subscribe
leave a review we always appreciate it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
you